did your mind immediately jump to I have  cancer no okay I just thought huh you  know maybe it's just some leakage in my  breast implants you know because I I  have breast implants but they're about  to come out were they were you planning  to take them out prior to this no do you  feel that having implants made it more  challenging to detect your brusky that's  a great question and the answer is yes  one hundred percent yes I wish I'd ever  had the breast implants put it in the  first place but as you said before it  was it was more difficult to detect this  is hard that I didn't need to have a  mastectomy although i I'm so aggressive  as just Janice being Janice is that I  said take him out about talk about just  take them out now they said that they  after the radiation it's going to harden  the implants which they in which they  already have after all the scraping of  scar tissue so now I'm just left a scar  tissue and this tuesday i'm about to go  in and have my first radiation